all rail workers are to stage a fresh
nationwide strike in the dispute over
pay jobs and conditions they're
threatening travel chaos at the height
of the summer holidays train drivers at
eight rail companies will walk out on
saturday the 30th of july marking the
first coordinated industrial action by
them since 1995 and of course it comes
after the rmt union which presents uh
represents other trained staff saying
that it will strike on wednesday the
27th of july and also over two days in
august well we can talk now to our next
guest mick whelan
who is the general secretary of azlev
joins us now from tolpodal in dorset uh
every year there's a festival to mark
the torpor martyrs who of course paved
the way for the trade union movement
thank you very much for being on the
program and just talk us through what
strike action you're planning and the
impact that it could have on commuters
and people who need to use the trains
well quite obviously when train drivers
don't uh come to work trains don't run
so there'll be virtually no services in
those areas and that saddens us we'd
much rather be talking to people to find
a way out of this but unfortunately no
one's coming to the table
what is the strike about what pay rise
are you looking for
we haven't put an exact figure on it but
most people don't understand that nobody
in railway industries had a pay rise for
three years
so in two years of pandemic um we were
key workers people were approaching us
we were getting other key workers to
work we're moving food and medicine
around the country
and when rpi was a lot lower uh the
pressure wasn't so much on but now we're
in year three and the cost of living
crisis is hitting all workers and we're
not seeing just train drivers but we've
seen people cwu the post we're seeing
barristers we've seen all sections now
saying enough is enough
you say you don't want to put an exact
figure on the pay rise that you're
looking for and inflation of course is
around 9.1 uh percent are you looking
for a pay rise to match and keep pace
with inflation
we'd like that standing still isn't
great standing still is standing still
and of course we wouldn't even be
standing still because we're not looking
retrospectively for the pay rises we
didn't get in the previous two years
we're saying this year everybody
deserves pay rise
but you won't put any figure on on what
that would be
well it's incredibly difficult for us
because as you know we're we're a
fractionalized industry so there's eight
companies by the time we finish the
probably 13. um they've all got
different terms conditions they all work
differently geographically and they've
all got different needs and you know we
don't work for the government we don't
work for the dft we don't work for the
treasury we work for arriva and tantalia
and all of these private companies and
they've all been making profits
throughout the pandemic and they're
making profits now and it seems council
intuitive to us that they're paying
their shareholders and taking money out
of the uk to fund state railways
elsewhere while we can't get pay rise
internally
what's the current median salary for a
train driver
roughly about 59 000 pounds
because i guess for a lot of our viewers
they might think that is actually
already quite a lot of money
and
probably for a lot of people is and i
look at other workers i think they
should have what we have but every time
i ask the question if we don't get it
when you give 22 percent to the nurses
when you give it to the fire brigades to
bring them up will you bring these other
public sector workers and it's not an
exhaustive list because so many people
deserve a proper living and a proper pay
rise yeah it goes very very quiet so we
don't enter into this politics of envy
uh debate for us it's about everybody's
entitled pay rise everybody should be on
the standard we have
but do you think that some if you were
talking about prioritizing do you think
that people on lower incomes should be
prioritized for pay rises
yes and in the public sector that's down
to the government we are actually still
in the private sector there may be
legislation coming for great british
railways and may come back in-house but
at this moment in time
what's actually happened is slightly
duplicitous the
companies have done a deal with the
government not to offer us more than two
percent we go to the company say that's
not enough the companies say well we
can't offer any more than government one
letters we go to the government they say
you've got to talk to the employers so
with this wonderful catch-22 situation
where they've done a deal um actually
smashing free collective bargaining i
mean it may even be illegal
uh and put us into this place where
we've got no place else to go
i just want to talk to you about the
labour party uh if i may at your agm in
may um assalah voted to remain
affiliated to the labour party but you
noted that there is a measure of
disquiet with the direction of the party
what exactly did you mean by that
i think there's a lot of traditionalists
who would like to see occasionally
labour stand up stand with workers more
regularly
we do believe it's the best game in town
for working people in the uk but we have
to put the offer out there we have to
show that we're different and we have to
show that we have the plans for the
recovery for the future and for that
just green transitions that should
create those high paid quality jobs that
people need
so do you think that labour
frankly aren't doing enough to show
they're on the same side as working
people
i see an awful lot of work days done
behind the scenes so i do see that there
is a massive amount being done i just
think that occasionally was
communicating more
okay thank you very much indeed uh mick
wheeling there over azliv thank you for
coming on the program today
thank you